vous les voulez en découdre avec moins
d'options bien sûr et a gagné à chaque
fois je crois arrête toi
on n'est pas fait pour être monogame à
bâle au tchad blake assez chic
guéri de l'infidélité on guérit pas
céder période il faut être honnête avec
soi-même d'une façon naturelle on n'est
pas fait pour être monogame mais ça peut
être une preuve d'amour j'adore ce rire
qui croient à la paire vague à la
fidélité franchement arrête moi j'ai
dans mon entourage et parmi mes aïeux
ces groupes qui sont incroyablement sida
les
chambres à coucher ma fille
annoncé des coupes mais vraiment je
connais pas mais pour rebondir sur les
la déclaration de faris est de plus en
plus de personnalités de people parlent
de leur fidélité ou pas c'est quelque
chose d'assez nouveau il ya encore
quelques temps il faisait très attention
à ça et yannick noah notamment dans le
documentaire qui lui est consacré sur
prime vidéo il a dit un truc assez
incroyable il a dit pour la première
fois de ma vie je suis célibataire je
m'endors seul je me réveille seul et il
dit vivre la plus belle période de sa
vie il est heureux d'être célibataire
parce que jamais réussi à être monogame
justement comme disparue donc ça
intéresse que la majorité des femmes
sont fidèles et si elles apprennent que
leur mari les a trompés mais si
37%
effectivement vous avez une belle photo
l'a
aidé à les frapper des gens d'accord
pour dire la vérité ça m'est arrivé ça
jamais été diffusé mais effectivement il
ya eu ou non il ya un studio c'est
normal mais non contre moi et je me
défaut à celle des ados
submergé par la colère armand se jette
sur son marteau et façades
j'ai lu quelques-uns qui était même
entraîner s'étaient entraînés ils
voulaient en découdre avec mon attention
bien sûr et a gagné à chaque fois je
suis pas tout dire arrête toi ça tu as
perdu une fois jamais jamais non je me
livrais troisième g14 end a été cohérent
être india 4e dan de quoi donc un coup
d'essai c'est hallucinant facilement en
plus non seulement ils parlent mal mais
en plus certains ont eu des gestes très
déplacé en ma présence mais vraiment qui
se fait balayer au sol là nous
suppliaient de montrer les images qu'on
n'a pas le droit c'est interdit on le
sait et c'est de la violence par intérim
donc là le gamin part directement foyer
donc on n'a jamais pu montrer ses jours
dimanche et pourtant les bars ont signé
pour ça qu'en même temps tu restais à la
famille à l'époque c'était toujours à
tf1 douze jours pourquoi la star ac n'a
pas pris toit pour gérer tous les gamins
landes en esata moi je pense que je sais
pourquoi cette info ouais mais ça oui je
suis parti un peu pas fâchés mais j'ai
quitté tf1 à l'époque on est en plein de
signatures de contrats s'est pas
entendus sur les contrats alors je pense
que je vais mal fait je suis parti comme
ça j'aurais peut-être pas dû donc
d'ailleurs je m'en excuse auprès de la
chaîne parce que c'est quand même grâce
à eux aujourd'hui j'en suis là c'est
systématiquement dans des familles
extrêmement modeste mais tous ou parfois
c'était des gens le père est avocat vous
n'êtes pas 12h02 et en mer du gard oui
on a eu des familles avec d'un chef
d'entreprise très riche en hausse en
belgique aux musiques en belgique
c'est muscu tout le temps tout l'argent
en permanence à ce type de pion dans
cinquante deux ans quand même déjà mais
on compte deux frères ça c'est son fond
de commerce
mais avec un garde du corps dos des cas
avec la plus volée tu vois tu as tué
serait pas une quête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
que malheureusement on n'est pas là pour
une bonne nouvelle comme non ça s'arrête
là en novembre suisse 18 novembre la
diffusion à la diffusion est ce que les
derniers épisodes ont déjà été tournés
ou pas du tout non on les interviews 9
septembre comme c'est quoi un peu
l'ambiance en ce moment est-ce que c'est
pas un peu triste la fin en tous les cas
là la fin les derniers épisodes de
tourner si c'est triste mais c'est bien
sûr le plateau est plutôt bonne parce
que parce qu'on est content de terminer
par l'épatant de terminer mais on a
envie de terminer ça plutôt en beauté
puis de profiter chacun des dessins des
autres et de l'équipe nous aviez marre
après 18 ans ont pas du tout mais pas du
tout d'acteurs et d'actrices
compagne aussi voulu venir parce qu'ils
sont fâchés après ben la chaîne tout
simplement parce qu'il doit on crie par
la presse mais parce qu'il faut parfois
très élégant à la presse vous l'avez
appris par la place à moins 18 ans mais
certains matins vous pourrez du petit
déjeuner vous avez ouvert le journal on
s'y attendait on en parlait mais vrai
qu'il ya eu une grande réunion sur les
plateaux et en action marseillaise je
pensais que j seraient conviés je n'y ai
pas été conviée puisqu'ils ont compris
que les gens qui étaient présents et
c'est vrai que je les lui dans la presse
moi je vais vous dire juste un petit mot
c'est que ayons la fierté grâce à vous
grâce à nous si un petit peu c'est qu'on
est la plus belle histoire
de la télévision en france voilà dix
huit ans de bonheur grâce à vous comme
j'ai dit hier nous nous étions sur le
plateau mais vous vous étiez derrière
vos écrans et sa personne pour nous
l'enlever voie la plus belle la vie
c'est vous c'est nous et
et c'était très très très beau avec
laurent qu'est vraiment un bon ami à moi
et qui est très touchée on est un peu
déçu de pleureuses de non mais c'est
vrai on est les plus émotifs c'est vrai
que
ça me fait de la peine de le voir alors
en mairie stature de laurent laveder
celui qui est tournée le plus simple
mais il était là bas ces dix huit heures
d'une vive voix ce que vous avez
rencontré l'amour dans la série ah oui
au début oui serge dupire bah oui mais
vous avez dans votre pays vous inscrire
non c'est pas mon mari mais j'ai eu une
histoire avec serge dupire qui jouent et
le compagnon de céline frémont et on
aimerait savoir semble quelques temps
il ya quinze ans et je sais bien se
goupiller de faire durer les histoires
où ma pauvre dame
ça il faut être très honnête quand on a
une grande différence d'âge parfois ça
passe mais il faut être il faut étonnant
parfois il ya les chemins ce secret et
ses essais et c'est normal tellement de
contre exemple à ce qu'elle dit je suis
désolé mais là julie gayet vient
d'épouser françois hollande la femme de
jean marie bigard ne je pense pas
qu'elle va le quitter de sitôt enfin et
des exonérations
pour l'exemple inverse au contraire on
parle plus d'une femme plus âgée c'est
vrai que c'est beaucoup plus rare et
elle l'a beaucoup dit déjà quand elles
étaient accueillies mika il ya pas de
n'y a pas de coupe tu ne vois aucun
mâcon
sur tout ça parce que son mec et mister
tahiti
quand il est tombé amoureux très
longtemps avez vous fait quoi il a vu
chez moi soit avec lui pour la première
fois évidemment il y avait un côté
trophée dit justement qui se faisait
souvent drague et parfois même devant
elle avait parfaitement d'accord elle a
rajouté aussi un truc très important
c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle veut refaire
sa vie elle est célibataire elle veut
quelqu'un mais elle fera ce choix aussi
en fonction de sa fille parce qu'elle a
une petite fille